one of the biggest questions about the
future of the MCU is how can they outdo
the past eleven years
how can you outdo Iron Man Captain
America Thor the Hulk and how can you
outdo a villain so big and bad as Thanos
Marvel took their time over the years
and they developed many different
characters along the way and they
developed Thanos at the same time to all
come together in two giant movies two
movies that are considered by many to be
not only the greatest Marvel films of
all time but some of the greatest films
of all time in general so where does the
MCU go from here many new movies and
characters have been introduced for
phase 4 and phase 5 already and a lot of
characters are rumoured to be coming to
the MCU in those phases as well but one
thing we haven't really heard about yet
is who is going to be the next big bad
villain of the future phases
what possible villain could outdo Thanos
with the Infinity Gauntlet well it seems
like we may finally have our answer
thanks to an amazing leak about the
future of the MCU this leak comes from
the one and only Mikey Sutton mikey has
been responsible for many great leaks in
the past that have come true so he has
an amazing track record if you're
unfamiliar with who Mikey is he's the
one that originally dropped the bomb
that Spiderman would be entering the MCU
in Captain America Civil War which of
course we all know happened so today's
news about the MCS future big bad
villain comes from Mikey Sutton and
Mikey says that we're actually not going
to get one big bad villain we're going
to get two and if I ask you the question
which two big bad villains would you
actually like to see in the MCU if you
had a choice well these two villains are
probably who you would mention and they
are none other than Victor Von Doom or
Doctor Doom and Galactus now these are
two characters that Fox owned and now
Marvel owns thanks to the Disney Fox
deal
so for a very long time they could not
be used in the MCU but when word about
the Disney Fox deal got out we knew it
was only a matter of time until they
made their way into the MCU doom and
Galactus are right up there with vanos
as far as master villains of the Marvel
Universe and according to Mikey Sutton
we are in for a major treat with
Galactus and Doctor Doom in the future
of the MCU so let's go ahead and read
the exact
port and then we'll break it all down
after quick reminder that my 500
thousand subscriber giveaway will be
this afternoon so be sure to be on the
lookout and if you'd like a chance to
win a Nintendo switch be sure to
subscribe to my channel and click the
link in the description down below so
the report says there will not be a next
big bat in the MCU instead there will be
big bats two of them according to my
sources the MCU is planning on having
two major villains as part of its new
endgame in the next couple of phases all
roads lead to Doctor Doom and Galactus
so this first part of the leak is pretty
straightforward and really really
awesome
according to Mikey Sutton the next
couple of phases are all going to lead
to Doctor Doom and Galactus they're
going to build them up just like they
did Thanos in the first 11 years in the
nfinity saga none of the movies were
really about Thanos until we got to
infinity war and endgame he appeared in
some post-credit scenes and he appeared
briefly in guardians of the galaxy so
this is probably what you can expect to
see from Doctor Doom and Galactus they
probably won't throw them in movies at
first but you'll get little mentions of
them throughout the next phases and then
ultimately they will be introduced the
league goes on to say first
neither character will debut on Disney
Plus both are large chess pieces and the
acquisition of Fox these are a list
characters that fans and general
audiences will flock to see in theaters
to see them finally done correctly not
like in the Fantastic Four the rise of
the Silver Surfer where Galactus was
well a cloud so he's absolutely right
about that fans will simply flock to the
theaters just to see these characters
and he goes on to say that they are not
quirky minor league characters such as
she-hulk and Moon Knight and that is not
any disk towards she-hulk or Moon Knight
that is just simply how it is Doctor
Doom and Galactus are two of the
greatest villains to ever come from
Marvel and the fact that he says that
they're not going to appear on a Disney
Plus series is honestly really great
news I know that they're doing that with
some characters I know they're going to
have them be introduced in a Disney Plus
series and could possibly move on to be
in a future MCU movie and there have
been recent rumors going around that
Doctor Doom could be introduced in a
Disney Plus series at first possibly as
a good guy but then we would eventually
see him turn into a villain becoming
Doctor Doom
now this is appealing to some people but
dr. doom is huge this isn't just
somebody you can casually introduce
Marvel has the right idea you do have to
build him up over time you have to set
him up to be a major villain because he
is he's one of the greatest villains of
all time and the same goes for Galactus
you could never introduce Galactus and a
Disney Plus series the first time that
you see Galactus in the MCU has to be in
a very big movie so the fact that this
report says that we're not going to be
seeing them in a Disney Plus series is
really good news
Mikey goes on to say that no Halley's do
movie as publicly reported is dead and
will not be tweaked as a Disney Plus
show Holly script was written for Fox
not for Marvel Studios his version of
doom was not modeled for the MCU and
that has to mesh with the vision of the
upcoming writers and directors for the
Fantastic Four movie Disney spent
billions on Fox and Galactus and Doctor
Doom was a part of that reason
putting Doctor Doom on a Disney Plus
series to begin with is like paying you
to to perform at the Hard Rock Cafe and
again that is absolutely true it goes
back to what I said before you can't
just have them appear randomly they have
to be built up over the years and when
they're introduced it has to be in a big
movie in the Fantastic Four obviously
since Doctor Doom is a Fantastic Four
villain is the perfect opportunity to
introduce him especially because all of
the fans have been waiting for Marvel to
actually do the Fantastic Four and not
Foxx his report goes on to say how do
you top fan OHS and make it fresh you
double the dosage Doctor Doom has a
tragic human element a la Thanos and
kill monger the GREs bad guy in terms of
morality issues he has the emotional
depth that Kevin Feige feasts on he will
be Easter egg until he debuts on the big
screen he is going to have links to
other Marvel foes either politically
mystically or through business both
characters are in the embryo stage in
terms of MCU development but the Stanley
Jack Kirby and John Byrne runs on the
Fantastic Four will provide the skeleton
and soul dr. doom will delivered the
theatrical drama Galactus is power light
and spectacle what they'll be leading
towards is an epic battle fought on the
ground and in space a secret Wars if you
will no casting as of yet I am told
Viggo Mortensen has been tossed around
as a potential Doctor Doom but to my
knowledge hasn't been
yet again it's early this is the plan
for the moment big baddie no bring on
the bad guys your fly in the ointment
Mikey Sutton so that is Mikey's report
let's talk about a really really big
thing that he said at the end of this
report he said what they'll be leading
towards is an epic battle fought on the
ground and in space a secret Wars if you
will
now Secret Wars is something that a lot
of people have been very heavily
speculating is going to happen within
the next couple of phases Secret Wars
would really be the perfect ultimate
movie to bring all of the new characters
that are going to be in the MCU together
on screen because pretty much all of the
characters that we expect to be in the
MCU over the next handful of years are
in Secret Wars The Avengers are in
Secret Wars the x-men the Fantastic Four
a bunch of solo heroes and even though
the Beyonder is the one who sets up the
battle world Doctor Doom temporarily
steals his powers at some point in time
and it wouldn't really be that hard to
throw Galactus in there in fact if
Marvel really wanted to they could
replace the Beyonder in the storyline
with Galactus which would kind of make
sense because the way that this report
is described kind of seems like Doctor
Doom could end up being the herald for
Galactus and not to mention that when
the Russo brothers originally announced
that they would be taking a break from
directing Marvel movies they were asked
in an interview what it would take to
get them to come back to direct another
film and their answer was Secret Wars
Secret Wars would be a really really big
movie to tackle you would essentially
have more characters and Secret Wars
than you had an Avengers end game just
think of all the Avengers and then add
the x-men and the Fantastic Four so a
movie like that has to be done right and
who else is better to do it than the two
directors that did such an amazing job
bringing all of these characters
together in the first place with
infinity war and endgame and not to
mention that the Russo brothers have
recently said that they are sure they'll
find something soon that they can work
on with Marvel that could be Secret Wars
and then one final thing with this leak
is that it actually lines up with
another leak that we got several months
ago what both of the leaked state is
that there's going to be a ground war
and a cosmic war now that is something
that has been pretty much guessed for a
while we now have cosmic heroes like
Captain Marvel
Thor and the guardians of the galaxy and
then we obviously have our heroes back
on earth like Doctor Strange Wanda and
Vision Black Panther spider-man so on
and so forth so a battle in the cosmos
and a battle on earth separately are no
doubt coming
and according to Mikey Sutton the main
big bad villain for Earth is going to be
Doctor Doom and the main big bad villain
that is coming to the cosmos is going to
be the one and a link a lactis and this
really does make perfect sense because
again they have to top Thanos and that's
going to be insanely hard but by
introducing Doctor Doom and Galactus
that could certainly do the trick and if
we had a secret Wars about a world event
with all of the characters the Avengers
the x-men the Fantastic Four all in one
movie that would certainly top Avengers
end game so this is by far the most
exciting leak that we've heard in a very
long time and again Mikey has an
excellent track record so let's hope
that this comes true and nothing changes
with Marvel but let me know what you
think about this what do you think about
Galactus and dr. doom being the next two
main big bad villains of the MCU let me
know in the comments down below and
again if you would like a chance to win
a Nintendo switch be sure to subscribe
to my channel follow me on Twitter and
click the link in description down below
to enter the giveaway also be sure to
check out my personal channel culture
captains if you're into comedy and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof